otros 12 opositores salieron de prisión
en la noche de este martes en venezuela
tras los indultos que otorgó el
presidente nicolás maduro en total son
110 los que tuvieron la medida de gracia
incluyendo 60 personas exiliadas la
figura más emblemática de esta lista es
roberto marrero mano derecha del líder
opositor juan guaidó bueno no le deseo a
nadie la cárcel
política - porque
el líder socialista venezolano actuó
dice con el fin de promover la
reconciliación nacional ese maduro que
no se ha dejado presionar ni se deja
presionar por nada ni nadie firmó con
este mismo lapicero el indulto
para avanzar en el diálogo pero esta
medida de gracia que no tiene
presidentes en dos décadas de chavismo
sería fruto de negociaciones con solo
algunos dirigentes opositores como el ex
candidato presidencial henrique capriles
informamos nuestro absoluto
desconocimiento a las negociaciones en
consultas realizadas a título personal
entre el régimen de nicolás maduro y los
dirigentes henrique capriles y stalin
gonzález juan guaidó reconocido como
presidente interino de venezuela por más
de 50 países y procesado en más de media
docena de casos por el poder judicial no
está entre los perdonados por su parte
eeuu minimizó el indulto conseguido por
maduro asegurando no dejarse engañar por
un gesto puramente simbólico